Hey youtubers, it’s charlie.
Time for my Game of Thrones Season 4 Preview
for Theon.
I hope you’re not to squeamish, because
this is probably going to get messy.
ewwww
So I’m in the middle of a trip to new york,
so hopefully you’re seeing this in a timely
manner.
Spoilers for everything in seasons 1 through
3 and the partial spoilers for book 5.
So Theon’s story has been altered a lot
from the books.
Season 3 presumably follows the first half
of events from Book 3, but because David Benioff
and DB Weiss still wanted to use the actor
that plays theon they added a lot of scenes
that we never saw in the books.
In the books we don’t meet Theon until the
beginning of Book 5 and by then he’s already
been tortured and turned into Reek.
So part of the horror of his situation is
him remembering all of his torture in his
POV chapters.
So season 3 just literally showed us some
of his journey from Theon to Reek.
And I don’t know about you but I’m not
a huge fan of horror, so I did have to turn
away a few times.
Since they spent so much time in that torture
chamber in season 3 I think that just to speed
things along they’ll use most of Theon’s
story from Book 5, so that he’ll be traveling
around with Ramsay Snow as Reek.
They probably won’t change his appearance
too much, but in the books it said that people
that knew Theon didn’t recognize him as
reek.
But Ramsay Snow pretty much treats him like
an animal, so if you remember how the Brave
companions treated Jaime after they cut his
hand off, that’s pretty much what it’s
going to be like between Ramsay Snow and Theon
for the duration of season 4.
If you remember Tyrion’s disfigurement after
the battle of blackwater bay too, they really
toned it down from the books, so since Theon
is supposed to look like an old man after
he becomes reek I think they’ll tone that
down too so that the actor is still recognizable.
Even if you haven’t read the books what
did you think about the scenes with him getting
tortured last year?
Do you think it was necessary?
Or would you have rather they have just shown
the body parts that Ramsay Snow kept mailing
people.
Sometimes when you don’t show something
it comes across as waay worse just because
your imagination fills in the blanks.
So let’s jump deep into season 4.
If you remember, his sister left to rescue
him at the end of Season 3, in the books she
eventually gets capture by stannis’ fleet
before they make it to the wall.
If you haven’t seen it, I just did a video
for Stannis in season 4.
So watch that if you want to learn more about
Stannis at the wall.
Since Ramsay Snow eventually gets captured
by Stannis while Theon is with him, I think
they’ll just accelerate this so that by
the time Stannis makes it to the wall with
his fleet, both Theon and his sister will
be with him.
But what will theon be doing while all this
is happening?
There’s a whole wedding subplot that may
or may not play out.
Because Theon is considered a minor character
they might not give it a full scene.
Most of the minor characters like Theon and
Sam do get their major moments, but most of
their story happens off screen.
I wouldn’t consider Theon being sent to
stannis’ army as an escape for him, since
he can’t undo the mental and physical damage
that was done to him, but after hitting rock
bottom he does start to regain some of his
humanity and remember who he is.
If I didn’t make it clear before, all that
torture actually does make him forget who
he is for a while.
That’s where that name Reek comes from.
He basically gets brainwashed, but I only
think we’ll see a little of that in season
4.
Let me know what you think though.
How much of Reek Theon will we see in season
4?
And how much longer will he be in that dungeon?
Do you think he’ll stay in the dungeon till
season 5 and all of his scenes from book 5
won’t happen.
I think they’ll add a lot of implied scenes
and yes he will be in the dungeon through
the first few episodes.
But I do think that he’ll make it to the
wall with Stannis and his sister in tow.
My next game of thrones season 4 video will
be for Varys.
Be sure to subscribe to get that.
I’ll try to post that on Monday.
Like I said I’m in New York for a few days
so I’m also trying to get my Sherlock giveaway
winners video out tonight too.
Tomorrow is also a new episode of Legend of
Korra.
Since I’m travelling I might not be able
to post that till Saturday Morning but I’ll
post an update on social.
As always it really helps me out when you
like and share this video, thank you so much
you guys are all awesome.
You can click here to watch my other Game
of Thrones Season 4 videos, I just did one
for Stannis and Melisandre, and you can click
here to watch my preview for episode 2 and
3 of agents of Shield.
Thanks so much guys, high fives!